first the critics are Oppenheimer and
couldn't stop raving about it but what
does everyone else have to say about
Christopher Nolan's three-hour long bio
pack World War II movies are a dime a
dozen having populated The Cinematic
landscape for many decades taking place
everywhere from the front lines to
submarines deep in the ocean these films
have thoroughly covered the globe
spanning conflict in numerous different
ways each
scalps
and I want my Scouts Christopher Nolan
is one such director to explore the war
through his big screen work doing so for
the first time via 2017's Dunkirk six
years after that war Thriller took
theaters by storm the seasoned filmmaker
is giving moviegoers a different kind of
World War II drama in the form of the
highly anticipated biopic Oppenheimer as
a title implies Oppenheimer puts the
focus on one of the masterminds behind
the atomic bomb J Robert Oppenheimer
throughout the film The esteemed
scientist Works tirelessly to develop
the super weapon that ultimately played
a major role in the end of World War II
all while grappling with the ethical
issues that stem from creating such a
destructive object
strong force
before the Nazis done this plot the
presentation the performances and more
resulted in stunned first critical
reactions to the film on social media
following its Premiere in Paris now at
long last Oppenheimer has made its way
to theaters for General moviegoers to
see for themselves given Christopher
Nolan's Stellar track record as a
director up to this point it should come
as no surprise that Oppenheimer is
already being regarded as yet another
must-see masterclass by many folks on
Twitter one user wrote I'm telling you
all Oppenheimer is a must watch it's so
awe inspired with a fabulous cast great
cinematography and the score another
user found Oppenheimer to be absolutely
incredible as well citing the score and
the performances of Killian Murphy and
Robert Downey Jr as some of the film's
highlights speaking of performances
another Twitter review read my man Nolan
keeps winning another five stars
Masterpiece another great performance
from Benny safety keeping their
positivity going another user wasn't
afraid to use the word Masterpiece
either and went on to elaborate on the
range of emotions experience writing I
got mad I got sad I was amazed and
enjoyed every second of it another user
wholeheartedly agreed and went so far as
to say Oppenheimer is the movie of the
decade A Perfect Blend of History
Science tension and even philosophy
Christopher Nolan you've done it again
beyond that one user believes that
Oppenheimer is one of the best projects
Nolan has ever put together they tweeted
this is a top two Northern Movie
masterful storytelling I need to watch
it again but the theaters are so booked
bearing in mind the competition that's a
stronger compliment as one can give
still for as much praise as Oppenheimer
has received it has proven somewhat
divisive when it comes to one of its key
aspects the three hour run time one user
tweeted Oppenheimer was literally a
masterpiece only thing is that it's too
long another user agreed with this
sentiment and wrote in part some will go
crazy some will dislike a three-hour
long courtroom slash interrogation drama
bored to death of course there are
plenty of people who think that the film
manages to avoid feeling like it's as
long as it is my news are tweeted it's
three hours long but doesn't feel like
it at all this is a must watch the story
of Jay rubber Oppenheimer is so surreal
it'll make you contemplate things others
were definitely on the same wavelength
and quick to agree that the sheer
quality of the movie made its runtime
irrelevant one user wrote it was
incredible three hours long and it only
felt like half of that really nice
pacing editing and sound design if
you're a Christopher Nolan fan a history
buff or both and have three hours to
spare Oppenheimer is now playing
exclusively in theaters